今日は外れ出場です皆さん水切りってしたことありますでしょうか
ちょっとやってみましょうかいきますこういう数です
とって
me
はーいどうでしょうか結構一瞬の形も大事でこれで平べったいやつかすると
めちゃくちゃとですよね
大失敗なんか北詐欺ネットで調べまして水切りの世界1チャンピオンが日本人の施設ん
世界1-1
水着見たらなーんてやったらバーってもうめっちゃ殺す思いました網膜なるには結局
努力するしかないと思ったので
じゃあ今から3月リー旋回トップします
軽く言ったけどすごい人がもう頑張るしかも多分今日1日だと無理だと思うんで
ちょっとコツコツと海瀬重ねていって水切り1000回やった結果
うなくなるのかどうかを検証していきたいとおもいます池津ビル
俺の風情を味わっています
kanoa ん
では早速スタートですヒット目
[音楽]
ん
うらば掃除って逆全部終わったと分
うん
ほらほら頃います
ええええええ
2つうまくなるコツがあるとためがつかめるようになるまで頑張ります
[音楽]
今30回終わったんですがマジでキツイですこれやばいで4倍ください
テニスボールのマヤ分いやー良い
あっはぁ
me
ね当たった今フェイス国内で向こう岸まで言った数が
[音楽]
are no カードでバウンドしなかったんですよ
ぼいんっ
頃の3つ入ってますよ覚えてきたなぁ
[音楽]
俺矢部も同4 a
配布
えっもうねね編集石2つになったん
[音楽]
4日酔いらっしゃいはいそれに立っ回行きました
やっ回やったかなそうなんですけどきついですね
うぜーがめちゃくちゃきついですけど着時前何かコツをつかめているような気がします
わかんないですけど
石エラー1後投げれかけとなりなクエリ面で平行に投げるのがこっちなのかなと思い
ました
頑張っていきます
[音楽]
妙
トライアングルフォースすげー
してねー
健康をます
[音楽]
山ザック思想まずで結構19てくれから形になりを買ってきました
四方投げすぎでしょうかやばいならまずはシクは一歩痛い
また乗った
ん
ザッハイオン
やっぱカフェ食べ
雨が降ってるので一時絶対
81日目やって思ったんですけども5霧に適したいい子じゃないと練習にならないので
まず3隻日の練習する前にラギア推移し広いから始めようと思いますダフ
声がこれこういうのが一番いいです
いいます
[音楽]
by 結構集まったんで今日も元気に練習していこうと思いまーす
持って
[音楽]
すってー理由だったらいけるんじゃなーいっ
うわやばいよ今のやばいよ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ええええええ
どうぞありがとうございました
めっちゃ来ていて1日安全だけ肩は大丈夫なんだけどあ税制にこの行為に疲れてきまし
た
どんな旅せずに上手くなってる気がするんだよもうちょっと今日はがんばります
tee
ええええええ
ん
はいさーいあっはい
ああああああ
ch
ええええええ
[音楽]
くれん
腕がやばいまずで方ここがすごいこだわりたぶん普通の3軒の1日の投げて位水木と
ピースを軽く終わっている気がします
ええええええ
しています
[音楽]
黒川レーサー
ああ1年って200頭ぐらいが多分
限界な気がします方がキツイのと一丁いかなくなってくるんでちょっと今日はがんばっ
ても100回だけ投げて帰ります
[音楽]
図4 a 500円話したん pets 汗かきますあとハンバーガー
頑張ってございますこれがいまーす
第二強が混ぜていきましょうあの石を投げつけたり言ってると思ったんですけど
e 賞けど投げるのが非常にもったいなく感じてきました
1勝を挙げたくあり
前ずつやってみましたん
ジャマーやばいん
おっ設置プロジェクト言ってちゃめちゃえっ
dee
あよろしかっ派
[音楽]
dea
すげー1 a
アップってやばい普通各自何を狙ってるよ
ren
ええええええ
[音楽]
ん
me
ロックや変わりましたはいて上げてご覧くださいなぎる医師も出てね
結構どんな石が水切り知らせ方が分かってきたんでだいぶ医師に特徴が出てきました
基本平べった奴がやっぱり遠くまでいきますあと丸いやつ
頑張ってきます
[音楽]
プロの方ですからない待ってやばいまじ
あるので辛い
ええええええ
やばいんじゃないよね乳母の
もうに爪た飛んでたん
[音楽]
nsa はよ車あのー
阿部せん
熱中症になっちゃめっちゃちょっと猛暑日なんで209投げるのがさと形的にも体力的
にも限界だと思います
また明日頑張ります
[音楽]
はいトイレ行も頑張っていきましょう
ああああああ
ほっぺございまーん
月でやばす
この巻は900ができます橋てきたあああ
[音楽]
やばいやばいやめちゃめちゃいい
ございません
体力の限界ですね
[音楽]
あー軒か行ってきて投げないああ
me
[音楽]
さあ
素手で900回投げられましたどこに100カイで1000回達成なんですけど
地下連続で400円だけれど方がやばいですここで突かれちゃんと入れて投げてるんで
パワーは上がってると思うんで1000回達成した後にどれくらい飛ぶんでしょうか
楽しみでしたまた明日
た際は最終日だと思います今日は900回から1000回やっていこうと思いますね計
9肩の筋肉もついてきてホンディ者はいいと思うのでもう最終調整の100回だと思っ
てしっかり投げ込んでいきたいと思いますでは
me
[音楽]
rar
なぜぼかぁ
受けなけれどがーい槍ヶ岳ながら archicad ハゼを急落て that are
her
ハイツ力で旋回終わりました
使ったですねー方的な絆がメっちゃったんですけど
1000回投げてかなりいろんなことが学べた気がしますそれで最後にちょっとよりて
米の一応もう
保存しといたんでこの石を使って1000回練習した後にどれくらい最初と変わって
いるのか比較してみようと思います旋回頑張ってきて今まで思い出しすべての気持ちを
込めて東急しようと思います
[音楽]
あああああ
ああああああ
やばくねぇ
[音楽]
me
teame
ana あああっ
ahaan
me
[音楽]
can you do
me
goo
ああああああ